we're here with the incredible
firefighter cat lewis
and the rest of the long beach fire
department and their loved ones
[Applause]
um okay before the break we watched the
surprise when we told them that we were
to make um their firehouse over
um drew crewmember and my design partner
in crime mikal welch and i planned out
every single inch of their new space
together so oh gosh
i hope you like the end result check out
what happened when mikael
came to reveal what we had worked so
hard on oh god
[Music]
i'm here at a firehouse to surprise some
lucky firemen and in particular one
lucky firewoman i just wish there was
some easier way to get downstairs
i'm mattel from the drew barrymore show
and drew sent me here to help you guys
out with a fantastic makeover this is a
very important project not just to drew
but to myself as well because my
brother's a firefighter so
you know are you ready to see the space
oh yeah all right let's go check it out
all right cat bring those boys in
[Applause]
look at that awesome
wow
[Applause]
we really wanted you guys to have an
awesome recreational space where you can
just chill and relax so drew and i want
to give a huge shout out to burke decor
for providing furniture to deck out this
entire space
check out the beautiful camille dining
chair it's perfect for this area we kept
the original dining table but we brought
in these beautiful woven dining chairs
we used some of drew's paint flower home
so we've got white daisy on the top of
the walls and soft black on the bottom
to really finish out the space now
before i don't even know how you could
see the carpet it was so dark so drew
and i have given you some beautiful
carpet just to brighten up the room a
little bit so remember you had those red
partial drapes up here well now we've
given you some beautiful roman shades
that go all the way down it's going to
keep the sunlight out and best of all
give you full coverage now cat told me
you boys can get a little messy at times
so we've given you clothes storage which
will help keep these high traffic areas
clear and organized i know this wall
right here is really important so we
wanted to put up several firemen's hats
this pays homage to them on this wall
but it's actually a cool installation i
think
really cool
i know one of the things that you guys
really needed was a coffee bar well you
had a coffee bar but it wasn't like the
coffee
well we've decked out a completely
furnished coffee bar as you can see here
and if you look all the way on the end
that's not a microwave my friends this
is the airfryer and toaster from the
beautiful line by drewberry
drew and i really wanted to give back to
you and your community and we hope this
gesture will make things better and at
least give you a nice place to come and
relax so i think the main question here
is the cat did drew and i passed the
test oh my god absolutely this is
honestly incredible it's better than i
think we could have wished for and i
know i speak on behalf of the entire
team when i say we are
very thankful and appreciative and um
let's enjoy the space everybody pick a
chair
i got my usual yeah this is hot
look at these guys
already
this is nice
you see it
that's right thank you drew
mchale and i really kind of were
inspired by
a little bit of a hotel look if you will
and hotels are very sleek and chic
but
looking around your space you need a lot
of comfortable cozy seating
so we just went with like
big furniture that you could sink into
and feel really comfortable lots of
seating whether it's at the dining room
or along the walls in front of the tv
and your beautiful photographs and your
ever so beautiful fire helmets we wanted
to incorporate that into the space in an
artistic way to honoring your history
and where you've been and where you're
going so true speaking of helmets um the
helmet is an integral part of our
equipment
and since you were so gracious to donate
a renovation to our firehouse we wanted
to do something for you sam can you come
down this way
[Applause]
hold on
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
and honor you guys that's what michelle
and i wanted to do
was give you a space worthy of you
thank you so much for including
of the long me fire department thank you
to my best partner in design crime
mikael welch and a big thank thanks to
burke decor because they
really provided everything and there
were things we were trying to get and we
couldn't and burke decor completely
saved the day and everything looked
exactly to our specifications so thank
you
[Music]